the Trump administration is taking a
very aggressive and mostly unprecedented
stance against the International
Criminal Court and this is a major red
flag yet another red flag and it's part
of this broader attack that we've been
talking about on really the basic idea
that the United States is not some
isolated power that exists unilaterally
in a vacuum but the reality that most of
our allies understand that the United
States exists really as a country on a
planet with lots of other countries and
many other people and we need to
recognize the importance of
international authorities that the world
community says are going to be abided by
and the ICC the International Criminal
Court is an international tribunal
that's at the Hague in the Netherlands
it has the jurisdiction to prosecute
individuals for the international crimes
of genocide crimes against humanity war
crimes and the ICC has been exploring
it's been known that they've been
looking into investigating whether the
United States and and specifically
Americans and this is an important
distinction Americans operating on the
behalf of the United States committed
war crimes in Afghanistan and war crimes
by American troops is something that a
lot of people flat-out don't want to
talk about right they're very quick to
debate the war on drugs and
incarceration domestically but when you
say hey you know some of the actions
undertaken under the flag of the United
States by individuals overseas those
could also be crimes that's not a
conversation that as many people are
sort of eager to have in comes Donald
Trump and Donald Trump now is
threatening sanctions against the judges
of the ICC if indeed this investigation
goes forward and of course none other
than Donald Trump's current and third
national security adviser John Bolton is
going to be making this announcement and
he is straight-up going to call the
I see see illegitimate quote from a
draft version of a statement says the
United States will use any means
necessary to protect our citizens and
those of our allies from unjust
prosecution by this illegitimate court
the background on this is one that
doesn't point to illegitimate see it
points to lack of recognition by the
United States the ICC has had this sort
of bumpy history with the United States
where back in 2002 when it was
established via the Rome treaty George W
Bush opposed it and Obama was able to
make some advancements and working
together with the ICC and Trump now
going in the exact opposite direction so
there's a meta story here and then
there's like a meta meta story the meta
story is that of the Trump
administration continuing to question
International Authority criticizing
international organizations and
multilateral treaties and deals that
have been made criticizing our allies
and foreign countries in general and
adopting this sort of no one controls us
attitude which is both the distraction
and it's also completely unrealistic in
2018 in this networked globalized world
in which we currently live that's the
meta story the meta meta story is about
crime organizations or rather
organizations like the ICC and how they
relate to how we conceive of crime and
what I mean by that is the following
crime as it exists today is
overwhelmingly focused not only on some
crimes over others but on the crimes of
individuals over the crimes of
corporations and of states we often talk
about there's too much focus on
marijuana versus white-collar crime
which is disproportionately committed by
white middle-class individuals right
versus the the war on drugs is a sort of
implicitly racially tinged way of
carrying out justice that's an important
analysis I maintain that that's an
important
but there's a bigger story which is that
all of that is a discussion about crimes
by individual people not on the behalf
of any country or corporation and there
is much less recourse for crimes that
are committed by companies and even less
recourse for crimes committed by
countries when a company knowingly
pollutes water and that leads to a ton
of people getting cancer and dying you
get a lawsuit sometimes it's in the form
of a mass tort sometimes it's in the
form of a class action and the company
effectively pays their way out they pay
money but individuals who are sort of
under the protection of the corporate
infrastructure if they did it as
individuals would go to prison often for
a long time but because of this veil of
protection that that is called
corporations in the United States you
rarely see jail time for the individuals
that are involved then we get to
countries which buy all sorts of legal
infrastructure are protected from these
decisions that are often made that lead
to the deaths of thousands of people or
tens of thousands of people or even
hundreds of thousands of people they are
effectively immune from consequences the
ICC the International Criminal Court is
one of the few institutions that can at
least try to hold the individuals within
governments accountable for decisions
that they make whether or not you agree
with the ICC organizations like the ICC
are hugely important they're a sign of
modernity they're a sign of
understanding the limits of sort of
domestic status quo criminal justice
systems and of course incomes Donald
Trump threatening one of those
institutions and what I want to invite
you to do is step out of your political
bubble the bubble you're in right now
and that might be like a libertarian
belief bubble could be a social justice
belief bubble whatever right I mean it's
not a partisan analysis think ahead like
a hundred years or maybe even five
hundred years when you think about not
only just globalization but trans Planet
marry trans globalization I guess would
be the way to refer to it the future
cannot be some Wild West where countries
do whatever they want and
decision-makers can't be held
accountable because we simply don't
recognize entities like the ICC if that
is the future in your mind that it's a
very very dark future and that's a
debate I'm very willing to have with
anybody that disagrees with me
absolutely disgusting
behavior by Donald Trump and hey by the
way no surprise that this is like one of
Bolton's things right it's no surprise
to anybody that bolton's the guy who's
going to be making this announcement I'm
really thrilled to tell you that today's
program is made possible in part by
better help.com slash Pakman as many of
you know I have been working very hard
on this program to reduce stigma around
mental health to reduce stigma around
seeking help and I have a family that is
very involved in mental health and if
you've not already heard about better
help it is a tremendous resource better
help gives you through your phone and
computer affordable private access to
licensed trained accredited experienced
psychologists counselors therapists and
clinical social workers who were
dedicated to helping you through
whatever is going on in your life you
just go to better help calm slash Pakman
fill out a questionnaire they will match
you with a counselor that will work best
for you they are LGBT friendly you can
even say I want a counselor who's not
religious if that's important to you if
your initial match isn't a good vibe you
can switch to a different counselor and
the beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over videophone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm slash Pakman it's
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube once again that is
better help calm slash PA que ma n